ده اشهر شقتها خلافات وانقسامات بين دول
الاتحاد
وتخللتها ضغوط شديده وتهديدات بتفكك السوق
اتفقت الدول الاعضاء حول تحديد سعر سقف
الغاز المستخدم في صناعه الكهرباء عند
مستوى 180 يورو ميغاوات الساعه
الاليه تفعل اذا تجاوز السعر والسقف ثلاثه
ايام متتاليه
وتدخلوا حيز التنفيذي في منتصفه فبراير
المقبل
اذا تجاوز السعر في الشهر المقبل
180 يورو للميجا وات في الساعه على مدار
ثلاثه ايام عمل ثانيا اذا تجاوز الفارق
بين السعر وفقا مؤشر
الاساسي للغاز المسالم في السوق العالميه
للغاز اذا تجاوز الخارق 35 يورو على ثلاثه
ايام عمل
الاتفاق يسمى اليه تصحيح السوق
الاليه المؤقته تقتضي زمنيه بعدم تفعيلها
اذا واجهت دوله واحده صعوبات في امدادات
الغاز او اذا ظل السعر في المستويات
المنخفضه وتراجعت والديه الغاز المسال نص
الاتفاق يتضمن المميزات الخاصه باليه
تصحيح السوق مثل ما اقتراحته المفوضيه
لكنه يقتضي حزمه من الضمانات القويه
المفوضيه تعتقد ان هذه الاليه مفيده لكنها
تتضمن مخاطر لذلك وضعنا ضمانه اضافيه
لحمايه مصالح مزودين الغاز المسال
والسيوله واستقرار اسواق المال واستهلاك
الغاز المجر انفردت باعتراضها على الاتفاق
النمس وهولندا اكلتهم احتفالتها بصوتهما
احتياطيات الغاز في السوق الاوروبيه بلغت
مستويات قياسيه
96% بالتالي لا خوف من شتاء هذا العام
المشكله تكمن في احتياطات العام 2023 حيث
سيعاني الاتحاد الاوروبي عزا من الغاز
المسال بنحوي 30 مليار متر مكعب حسب تقدير
وكاله الطاقه الدوليه ما قد يحد من تاثير
اليه تصحيح السوق التي حذيت بالمصادق هنا
نور الدين العربيه